okay we're playing black against akshay
2010 12 10 and he goes d4
now you guys want to see a king's indian
let's go knight f6 and then decide what
we're gonna do
we can do a king's indian we can do a
nimzo indian
now a nimzo indian is an opening that
flies under the radar
a lot of the time the benoni grunfeld
there's a lot of good openings
that i could expose you guys to
uh even the budapest is good but
let's play positionally let's play nimzo
indian e6
and hopefully he goes knight's e3 by the
way uh
one misconception knight c3 bishop
before is the nimzo indian
uh any other move does not technically
allow us to play the nimzo indian
per se uh and that's why we'll have to
play the queen's indian setup of the
bogo indian he goes e3 which is very
passive
it's not bad i mean it's a solid move
right that's the pawn but it blocks in
the bishop and
one good companion setup to the nimzo
indian is the queen's indian set up the
queen's indian instead of being
the move b6 the actual queen's indian
is knight f3 b6 this is an even better
version of it
now why might you ask are should we not
give a check on b4 well the thing to
understand is that bishop b4
is most effective in response to knight
c3 if we give a check here it's not bad
but he can go simply go bishop d2 and
then we don't have the same possibility
of capturing that knight on c3 and
ruining a structure
so instead i proposed the move b6 it
would also have been possible to go d5
transposing into a favorable queen's
gamma to client
fianchettoing the bishop
and look at the nice control we have
over the e4 square
now how should we proceed
uh developmentally nothing
particularly crazy here
we should control the center a little
bit with pawns the move being d5
and i think d5 is a great opportunity to
talk about
what i would call the uh bishop as an
extension of a pawn or sorry the other
way around
pawn is an extension of the bishop the
move d5 might grate on
uh it might be a little bit of an
eyesore for some people right red dragon
and reggae speedway thank you for the
subs
because you look at this move and you
say well doesn't it block
in the bishop doesn't it counter
counteract the whole point of bishop b7
well it does from the point of view that
it restricts the bishop temporarily
but if you think about what the overall
idea is which is to control
central squares the bishop acts and this
is what i mean
the pawn acts simply as an extension of
the bishop
if we put something on e4 later and
that thing on e4 is captured let's say
we put a knight
and then we recapture with a pawn you
guys should see that the bishop
will then be defending that pot in
addition
we obviously can take on c4 and reopen
the diagonal in fact
that would be one of the best moves here
but
uh let's not rush with that let's
complete our development where should
this bishop go
what do you guys think c5 is possible
but
not strictly necessary
bishop d6 would be beautiful square and
now our bishops are aimed at
white's king so let's make a mental note
to ourself
to check various tactics once we start
developing
okay so let's castle
and let's recapture with a pawn
now we've got very nice central control
here bishop to d3
so ideas well maybe he's preparing e4
but that's not a threat here because
we've got one two
three defenders on the square and only
two attackers
now how should we position our pieces
here
uh this knight on b8 should not go on c6
that's a big no-no because it blocks in
the c pawn as you guys know
and it blocks the bishop even further it
should definitely go to b7
to d7 now
in such situations also the move a6 is
often very effective
at stopping potential knight b5 ideas
knight b5 is not dangerous here because
the bishop can drop to e7
then we go a6 and it comes back to d6
but
later on uh for example if white's queen
is on c2
knight b5 becomes a much more dangerous
idea because if the bishop
drops to e7 then c7 might fall
now we could go a6 but
let's think for a second about what our
opponent wants our opponent perhaps
wants to play e4 opening up the center
that's not such a dangerous idea but i
don't really want to allow all of these
trades
i really don't so
let's start with the move rook e8 expand
or increasing our
clamp on the e4 square discouraging
white from going e4
just to make it difficult for white to
to breathe
hope this is all making sense so far i
realize this is a position which
may be unfamiliar to a lot of you and
that's precisely that's a good thing
you know hopefully when you get exposed
to these positions you see that the
logic
isn't all that crazy he goes queen c2
good good uh good play by our opponent
now as you guys can see knight p5
becomes a serious
positional threat because it would
necessitate us giving up the bishop
but we have a way to deal with it and we
don't have to play a6 we have a more
active move
which some of you guys have been
suggesting for a long time now
what am i talking about here this is a
move which not only takes the sting out
of knight b5
but also um increases our
you know turns up the temperature dial
on the center we are ready to play c5
now that everything is developed
this is a good time to play c5 knight b5
we can just drop the bishop
back to b8 that's what i love about such
moves
it's the fact that it creates this
escape square for the bishop
and we don't even move the bishop from
the sexy diagonal that it's on
now obviously we want to take with the
pawn just to keep
the integrity of our of our central
pawns and he's he shouldn't have done
that
now we have d4 ideas which may come with
devastating effect opening up this
bishop potential energy ladies and
gentlemen
this is why it's such an important cause
the potential energy of the bishop is
super high
it might still seem pretty lame but it
could win us the game
in fact it probably will
all right guys the tactics the potential
tactics of this position are
through the roof but let's be calm
let's be methodical what should we do
now what should we consider what's the
first move we should consider
well as i just indicated we should
definitely consider that queen c7
is a good move generally speaking but
it does fall into knight b5 picking off
this important bishop we should
definitely consider the move d4
now let's calculate d4e takes d4 okay
so d4e takes d4 what do we notice about
the position
as a result well now the rooks are in a
standoff
uh white's rook is defended by the
knight
so one thing that comes to mind is to
play d4 e takes d4 and now what move
logically stems from our observation
that the rook is defended by the knight
well bishop takes f3
okay so if you're following the line d4
takes bishop takes f3
if he takes the bishop what do we do in
that position
and everybody can visualize this that's
my point well that drops the rook
so he has to take our rook
but what happens then what do we gain
from that
and we're going to play this we can play
queen tixian and occupy the open file
and then give him a pretty nasty looking
jack on e1
so that would be one way of playing that
that doesn't end that's not mate because
he's going to have the king is going to
have g2
remember that when you take the knight
he takes gf
that does create a little love for the
king
so i wouldn't rush to do that i would
consider the other canada moves
perhaps trying to find something even
more convincing
and i'm actually looking right now
thank you butcher tacho yeah the space
opening up is important to notice for
sure
unacceptable sky get out of the stream
okay
thank you tapi uh t for pioca lamo thank
you so much
appreciate it man
with a human he's so funny but i have
something crazy to tell you folks
i propose that we play a move that's
perhaps very few of you are considering
because it's so anti-climactic
uh and yet at a very high level at a
grand master level
such moves are often well first we're
gonna take the rook
and i'll explain everything afterward
because we're low on time
i want to play it play this a little bit
faster and then simply see takes d4
sometimes the simplest uh continuation
can be the strongest
because it's the easiest to evaluate and
it keeps all of the pluses of the
position
think about it this way when you have
all of these active pieces you're
looking for ways to play
you have all of this potential energy
and you're transferring
into kinetic energy by taking on f3 and
doing all of this stuff you want to make
sure that you're not cashing in too soon
here we're keeping all of our pieces as
active as possible
because what i'm going to try to find is
some sort of a knockout blow i wasn't
too satisfied by taking on f3 i think
that was more complicated than it looked
what i'm trying to see here can we
straight away do something devastating
let's start with bringing our rook into
the game with brook to c8
the greek gif doesn't work or maybe it
does actually we'll see
let's start with this one i don't think
there's a downside to this
now we need to consider the greek if so
takes takes knight g4
queen h4
bishop okay so let's calculate takes
takes
check let's say he drops back queen h4
bishop f4 defending
uh the h2 square do we have anything in
that position folks
visualize visualize visualize
we do
takes takes knight g4 king g1 queen
takes f2
that pawn on f2 is undefended
because the knight on e2 blocks the
queen queen's defense of it
so this is complicated i have a sense
that perhaps white has some sort of a
reputation here
but it's a good practical choice i think
with full due respect at a 1400 level
it's going to be tremendously difficult
for somebody to refute this
check and
dropping in the queen oh but he does
have something i missed
but it's still good for us he does have
a way to defend this pawn
now the point is this is not checkmate
queen h2 queen h1 might seem like mate
but it's not because that knight could
slide on over to g1
uh and in doing so create an escape
square on e2 for the king
but oh no that that's not what i was
thinking but knight g3 is good
okay now this guy is playing really well
we need to bring some stuff in now give
me a second to think here
hmm now we can give him a check and go
king f1
yeah rookie is what i was thinking of
let's go rookie a
let's bring the rook back into the game
yeah now it gets complicated now this
guy is definitely uh
out calculating me here so let's see
this is super complicated position
there's some beautiful ideas
i'll i'll uh fill you guys in on
everything afterward but
hopefully you can excuse me for being
for calculating here there
are some incredible tactical ideas here
he disconnected okay
so what's the idea of rookie the idea is
simply to transfer the rokin attack
tonight but that's not the only
idea the main idea is to make sure that
the rook controls the e2 square why is
that important
the reason that is important is because
i'm afraid that the king will eventually
make a mad dash to the center
and i want to make sure that if that
happens the stroke on ea doesn't allow
that to happen
does that make sense okay so he goes
there that looks like a mistake
that looks like a mistake
but i can't exactly refute it men
this dude one second
okay let's bring
hmm let's let's give him a check let's
give him a check
and then let's bring this knight on d7
it's not doing anything
this is an all hands on deck effort we
need every piece involved every piece
participating
let's get this night involved
if that makes sense
this is a super interesting and very
instructive position that can show you
how tactical chess can become
we have some incredible ideas here
in our camp
and he's got some amazing defensive
ideas in his
i'm trying to get a get a hold of them
but they're very difficult to
to understand everything here this is
super cool guys there's
so i'm looking at a stunning line
but i'll fill you guys in on it shortly
don't worry i'm not cheating
so what we're threatening here is to
take and go knight f3 that's one thing
we're threatening
oh my god
oh my god i'm gonna knock your socks off
with a with a line here i just
i hope he goes something like queen
before
oh there's an absolutely incredible idea
but it only if he gets his queen out
away which i don't think he will
oh my god guys this is this is beautiful
oh this is you nobody wants to go
anywhere trust me
trust me you will find this idea
stunning
okay bishop e2 now wait a minute
let me think let me think
knight f3
i'm thinking
oh my god
yeah i like d3 let's go d3
yeah d3 of course d3 is the most obvious
move but
um it's not the most
beautiful i wanted to find something
more beautiful but it is what it is
just forcing him just to do something
this is poggers we had an insane draw
guys
oh my goodness this is this is super
exciting business
now i have to take my hat off for this
this guy he is playing out of his mind
and he takes which is correct i think we
take
he takes the sting out of a lot of these
attacking opportunities now that he's
taken a night
which is very unfortunate but it is what
it is
oh god that's correct i think
and what if i go rookie two though
i think we can go here now look at this
if he takes we have checkmate check
and meet with the knight on h2
done you're getting outplayed yeah
that's checking now that wasn't even the
tip of the iceberg unfortunately a lot
of it will remain behind the scenes
by the way if knight takes c2
chakarrooski
knight u1 and checkmate on h2 but that
is literally the tip of the iceberg
okay we need to unpack some of this some
of this amazingness if you guys want
we need to unpack some of this
amazingness
okay so
we all want to go right to the end so
let me walk but but let's be patient
because i think there's a couple of
instructive moments in the beginning i'm
on three three nine one
now imzo indian is uh
knight's e3 bishop before i think of
groupoid
okay that's the nimzo indian white's
other main moves are knight f3 and then
the queen's indian is b6
and the catalan is g3 so there's there's
a trifecta here a trifecta of responses
to the movie six
at a club player level knight c3 is more
common at a grand master level knight f3
and g3 are more common
all three are good i mean and all three
lead to completely different types of
positions we're not going to delve into
the details
e3 is is is innocuous it's not bad but
it's
there's no need to play it immediately
okay so e3 knight f3
bishop b2 he's playing okay just again
just kind of passive castles bishop d6
and the way that i would play this with
white
is probably b3 thank you cash l
with a prime thank you guys man all
these subs are just crazy
so this is um he's relinquishing the
tension and giving us
everything that we want like an ideal
setup if that makes sense
i would have gotten b3 and fian get out
the bishop and then you get a very
combative position you know
white's super solid black has no
problems
but it's uh it's just a position it's a
complex structure
if uh c5 then we simply take it c5
blunders upon that's why we put our
one of the benefits of putting upon b6
is it prevents c5 does that make sense
uh sam yeah
so knight c3 cd bishop d3 repositioning
the bishop
knight b to d7 rookie one
rookie eight stopping e4 and queen c2
and now c5 the fun begins again
a6 would be fine to prevent knight b5
but i didn't want to allow e4
which potentially leads to a mass
trade on e4 now black again black is is
doing completely fine here
uh takes takes and now what's the
typical idea in such a position that's
to play knight f6 and knight d5
the square in front of the isolated pawn
is what we want to blockade
usually with a knight black is doing
well here thank you norb double07
gifting to graph
but it's mundane it's two vanilla we
want to keep pieces on the board
okay
okay
so c5 c5
uh adding to the central tension and d
takes d5
so again very clearly you can you guys
can see at a 14 1500 level
the uh difficulty that a lot of people
have in keeping the tension
right they want clarity in the center so
he captures on c5 which is a big
uh positional concession giving us more
control over the center
and giving this bishop a uh pathway
after a potential d4 that's what made
all of this tactic
tactics possible so this is very very
uh typical mistake at um
at this level and i don't mean that you
know disparagingly like oh no
one second i'm just throwing away the
wrappers
and you know i don't mean that
disparagingly but
uh but but it is but it is very common
to see this
okay let's turn the light off actually
set the tone here
okay so what should white have done
instead
this is called the hanging pawn
structure by the way yeah it is called
the hanging pawn structure
um so what should white have done
instead probably b3 bishop b2 would have
been
uh would have been a better idea
okay so dc bc and fi and now he goes b3
and now we go d4 opening up the bishop
let the fun begin guys yeah in the dark
are you guys ready for the fun so
um our initial idea was to play bishop
takes f3
rook takes c8 check queen takes e8
g takes f3 checkers
and king g2 but i didn't find a
continuation here that was satisfactory
uh which may seem crazy to you guys
they're like wow look at this but but
it's actually not because
there's just no squares around white's
king that can be accessed by any of
black's pieces
we can play c takes d4 but now the
knight can drop to e4 in fact this queen
could end up being vulnerable
because of some sort of bishop b2 at the
right moment oops
so he did not mean to open this game so
having seen that i rejected this i
considered taking with the knight on e8
to pave the way for the queen like this
but then y can intercept it with f4
also uh not just
wasn't particularly happy with this and
so
you need to take often to be able to
take a step back and see the bigger
picture and say
well is any of this necessary do we need
to
uh go into these details or can we just
play it simple
and i realize that we haven't sacrificed
anything yet
so we can simply recapture everything
and we'll have a huge attack
rook takes c1 i take c1 cd
now i've reconsidered i wanna i want to
turn the lights on i feel like it's
distracting
it's gonna it's gonna distract people
sorry it's gonna distract people and i
want us to be to be focused on the fun
tactics here
all right so e2 uh if knight e4
we have a very pretty uh tactical
sequence here guys
that this is instructive you you want to
listen to this trust me
everybody wants to listen because this
is going to be really cool
so in such a position we need to make an
observation
that this knight on e1 is undefended and
it's on the first drink everybody sees
that right
so in your mind you should be thinking
ah if we put something on the e
file at some point then we're going to
create a pin but if we do that
immediately if we play queen e7 here
the issue is that y can take on f6 and
it's check
so how can we modify this idea
to account for that flaw
okay so we can consider bishop takes
first and now queen e7
that's a good idea right we can't take
the rook because it made but
there's another flaw what's the other
flaw
in uh the in the ointment here what can
i do
white can play f3 supporting the bishop
bishop takes h7 is not an issue
that that would we would be happy with
this because we win a piece we win a
piece guys bishop takes a8
again listen carefully queen takes c1 is
checkmate
but the real problem is f3 preserving
the bishop so
now again continuing our logic
we have another thing to troubleshoot
the concept that white
white white can play f3 so how else can
we attempt to orchestrate
uh this sequence what what else can we
do what are the other candidate moves
who can come up with another idea
queen h4 is not possible here okay
but you guys are jumping the gun bishop
takes c4
is not the only way that we could
execute this particular idea how else
can we execute
what's the other option what's what's on
the menu we can play knight takes e4
we can play knight takes c4 and queen e7
right and i think you guys might be
assuming
well didn't we just discuss this right
why does f3
but that that's where i differ i'm going
through it step by step
and saying you know i know that even the
tiniest
uh seemingly insignificant difference
could have very important bearing
tactically
because now if we look at this position
suit very very carefully
what move can we notice that wasn't
possible
in the other position with knight
captures f5
beautiful attacking the bishop
this is checkmate white can try to give
a queen c4 check
the king drops to h8 and this line i
calculated
now all of a sudden we might be like
wait a second bishop takes
and oh the queen comes in blocks on f1
but what's the final line of the
sequence
boom displacing the king and winning the
queen
okay okay
so if bishop takes h7 we just go king h8
the knight is hanging white needs to
defend the knight i can do that by
moving the bishop to b2
and one way of exploiting this uh
this hanging bishop would be to go queen
to h4 even better than g6
just creating a devastating fork
i hope that makes sense anyways
blitzkrieg
that was a complicated logical process
but just want to show you that this is
all possible
none of it is crazy it's it just takes a
lot of
sort of getting your hands dirty kind of
calculation so 92
we begin with rook c8
um attacking the queen improving the
rook i feel i felt like there was no
downside to this move
although it turned out that maybe there
is and now of course
i would not go for this in one of my
games in one of my games i would have
probably preferred something more
straightforward
such as activating this knight to c5
or perhaps going queen a5
attacking the knight all of these moves
would probably be winning
because of the massive disparity in
peace activity
but this was too fun not to pass up
greek gifter
knight g4 now remember
from an earlier speed run three items on
the checklist
when you are evaluating a greek gift
sacrifice
item number one is do i have my three
main pieces in place
you need to have a bishop to do the
sacrifice with a knight that could
appear on g4 and a queen that could
appear on
h4 now you want to be flexible in that
regard sometimes the greek gifts can
happen with a queen on h5 or on h6 or
even on c7
right as long as the queen could have
access to h2
the pieces are in place the second
checklist item
is that um is that you have some
some way of meeting king g3 or king h3
right you don't want to assume that the
king has to drop back here
uh we we have many ways to beat this we
can bring the other knight into the game
uh oftentimes the move will be queen g5
here that's impossible because it
blunders the queen
we can go h5 the king is stuck in the
center clearly we have enough to keep
the attack going right
the third item on the checklist is what
was missed most often
and and that is the fact that you have
to ask yourself can my opponent bring
the h2 square
under control usually with the bishop
that can come out to f4
sometimes with a queen move such as
queen to d6
i can show you right off the top of my
head a million examples
of a very strong player going for a
great gift sacrifice and forgetting
that his opponent has some sort of um
some sort of way to defend that square
which was sort of hidden and they
completely missed it
oops i i was meaning to show you but
uh 22 2335 fide this is a serious player
not somebody who's joking around and
german championship and he goes bishop
h7 boom boom
he's accounted for this move because
he's got queen to g4
but what he hasn't accounted for is
queen to d3 covering
the h7 square then the queen swings to
g6 and the attack is over the game is
over because he sacked a piece
this isn't like some imaginary thing
very good players often miss these kinds
of things
so those are the three items on the gree
gift checklist i also wrote an article
on the greek gift
a couple of years ago for chess.com you
can check it out
hopefully that makes sense back to the
speedo
now we account
we counter for the two things did we
account for the third thing
well we did and the way that we
accounted for it is because we noticed
that f2
is also undefended which generally
doesn't
which is generally not the case uh
because there's usually a rook on f1
right that's the whole point
or there's some something defending the
piece uh but this is crushing
obviously so all those items are in
place
we can safely conclude that this is
going to lead to a long lasting attack
uh whether or not it's sound or not well
we don't know camo thank you
now queen takes d4 is what we decided
was a very nasty move that i had
initially missed
check king f1 and this knight on e2 is a
crucial defender because if we give
checkmate
wait a minute that's not checkmate he
goes knight g1
and the king is is not yet ready to
escape on e2 because the knight on g1
will be lost
but uh so what what can black do here to
to continue the attack what's what is
the materialistic approach for black
what would be one one way of continuing
here
well one way of continuing would be to
give a check and obviously to take the
knight
but if we look around the whole board
well we might notice that now all of a
sudden our knight is hanging queen takes
d7 and it seems like our attack fizzles
out
because this queen is simultaneously
covering the square
we could try to give a rookie a check
but that only helps white because the
king goes closer and closer to the other
side of the board where it's relatively
safe
bishop takes g2 here well then there's
knight takes g2
what's your follow-up
this check something like this and then
maybe slide into f1 maybe
maybe that looks interesting but i'm a
little bit skeptical
what about rookie 84 knight h2 that
would be another
very good candidate move knight h2 is
checkmate now
white has to find a way to cover the e
file so that the king still has an
escape
but among other things white can play f3
here a very nasty move
check king slides up to f2 doesn't seem
like there's a good follow-up here
black's stranded
so i think we have to act faster than
that
uh so i don't know i think it may very
well be that white is winning here that
black has no
good way to continue the attack um
because this knight is also hanging that
doesn't help my cause you can also play
a move like knight d
e5 and just hope for the best bring
another piece into the attack that's
another
important piece of advice for such
positions is if your
sense that the attack is about to fizzle
out you don't always need to go
desperado mode and give all these random
checks you can just
play a move like knight dd5 bring a
piece into the attack uh
and that doesn't require you to
calculate too much hope for the best
right maybe you'll take the bishop at
some point
that adds to the tension and well this
knight was also hanging
so that's not a bad option in in in
in certain positions so i think this
would have been white's best chance he
goes knight g3 which is totally
understandable
covering the h1 square so
after queen h2 check king f1
well we can't do that because that
blunders the queen
now i decided to bring my rook to e8 as
i explained during the game
uh in order to prevent the king from
escaping via e2 this move does this move
makes sense to everybody also it attacks
the night which was
a pretty good thing to be doing and
this is an important moment to mention
that you want to be very careful
about making the tempting moves when
you're attacking sometimes the threat is
stronger than its execution
and that's very true when you're
attacking you don't always want to give
all the checks that you can
sometimes you want to keep them in your
back pocket and here you're saving a
tempo by going rookie
if you give a check first and then you
decide to go rookie eight
well that could be counterproductive
because you're no longer attacking the
knight so
here you're forcing white to defend the
knight and then you're going to decide
whether or not to give the check
okay so queen to d2 and
now we decided decided to give a check
and i decided to bring the knight up to
e5
which is uh the move that i had
previously mentioned in response to
queen takes d4
this is a great example of of keeping
the tension of bringing another piece
into the attack
now what were the alternatives here some
of you were confused and
thought that i had checkmate why not
take the knight with a rook first well
remember
this helps white i think by allowing the
king closer to the center
and if you give this check remember that
the king doesn't have to move in
response to every check
you can simply block it with a bishop
and the attack is fizzled out the rook
is a crucial asset in the attack
giving it away is something that i would
only do if i ensure that there is
checkmate
before queen h2 okay
and now you want to go queen h2 and you
want to take but the king escapes toward
the center
i didn't see mate here king is a very
very slippery piece
we want to be super super careful about
how we do this
no we couldn't play it two moves before
because our rook came from c8
so another idea that was proposed to h5
h4
trying to dislodge the knight so we
could go queen h1 that's a phenomenal
idea i think maybe this would have been
winning too
because i don't see a way that white can
defend white's undeveloped
in the time that white takes to get get
the bishop out you're already gonna play
h4
that would be a very interesting idea uh
you know good way of seeing how pawns
can be involved in the attack it seems
slow but it's too much it's only two
moves and then you know you're already
attacking the knight so i don't know
what i would have done here
but yeah there is a sense in which
perhaps it's a little too slow but
knight d5 was associated
with an insanity with the insane ideas i
began to spawn here
and to see these insane ideas
let's first consider what would have
happened if white dishes developed the
bishop to b2
who can spot um
who can spot the most straightforward
way to victory
well it's not queen g2 queen g2 looks
beautiful
but you gotta adopt the business
approach here
and play not queen g2 but bishop g2
and after knight g2 why have we taken on
g2 we've taken out the pawn
why because the pawn was controlling a
very important square
this knight now accesses the square and
queen g1 is completely unstoppable to my
knowledge also we're attacking the queen
and this is where i began to see ideas
well here queen h1 is checkmate
but well now it's not checking checkmate
in two moves so what would be the most
beautiful checkmate though
and this will lead me segway me into
uh the really cool line that i saw
what other very pretty mating sequence
do we have here
we can do anything we want we can take
the queen but queen g1
and knight h2 is a very cool kind of
semi-smothered mate right
so that would win the game
very quickly but then i saw uh a line
that would be possible
if white let's say move the queen out of
the way which i don't know why you would
do that
but um let's say he he would do that
so let's say he would do that and i
wanna
wait so for the purposes of illustration
ladies and gentlemen
i want to show you just give me a second
please
yeah so if queen to a5
for example then we go bishop takes g2
knight takes g2 and now comes the beauty
now comes the beauty black to play and
win and this isn't only moving at this
point
you could probably go knight f3 but it's
far
less convincing because white can try to
block the e
file and get the get the king evacuated
boom
queen g1 check and this made me lose my
mind maybe it's not
as cool when i'm like showing it here um
it was cooler in my mind
but knight f3 check i mean come on this
is really cool look at this mate
and if the king goes to f1 the knight uh
gh2 is made
so that's still a pretty cool mate i
gotta say
that's pretty damn sexy so you sack the
bishop the queen and you deliver
checkmate
and uh if the queen goes to
f4 which i actually was expecting
this i actually was expecting
uh white to play but at this point you
can do really anything you wanting to
just take on d3 and
deliver made on g2
yeah this leads me to
uh envision some scenarios where
you might have a situation kind of like
this let me make some random moves here
just to
set up the position guys so i was
immediately thinking about a scenario
like this
this is all completely unnecessary
but i was thinking of some crazy
scenario where like
you basically at the end you sack the
rook or
a wrong wrong wrong wrong concept
you you have like a queen queen on b2
you distract it and then you get made on
f2
but in any case he goes bishop e2
and now we have a really cool draw we
had a really cool draw here
which well we're not interested in a
draw obviously
we could have gone check
knight f3 another sack now if he moves
his queen
then this is just checkmate black to
play and draw
this is a stunning drawing sequence but
again we're not interested in android
but still
black to play and draw guys who can spot
it
you got this you got this folks
come on sack on h1
queen sack boom perpetual
perpetual with one night against
all of white's pieces um
and this is a familiar idea perhaps to
some of you
this is a this is a common pattern it's
just a beautiful application of it
you have to sack the queen to clear
space for the night
to deliver the perpetual very nicely
done
okay in any case
we went d3 in order to open up the e
file the simplest
you know way to understand this right we
want the bishop to move
so that the rook once again bears
influence over the e-file
and um well this is completely winning
for many different reasons one of which
is just to take on d3
and i suppose
the fastest i'm trying to find the
fastest to win here
in case i get this position against
magnus so maybe maybe here we should go
let's think for a second who can help me
here
knight c4 takes takes
it's actually nuts oh i think still
takes just bishop g2
and and knight f3 no this is winning
this is the simplest
and and now it's over because it's worth
writing this mean and again
you know we could have this mate so this
is winning
bishop g4 knight g4 and again we have
control over the e file
and now rookie 2 is a very pretty move
uh
that that finishes the game immediately
if he takes with the knight instead
he takes this away with mate if he takes
with the queen
then um what do we have
here
hmm how do we win this game
i did i don't think alpha zero can
defend it um
the end oh d3 gives up the draw rook
takes c1 though king takes one maybe we
don't have a win here maybe we don't
have a win here
um i wonder what the computer moves here
because it's not showing me it's a
well it's not a dead draw i wouldn't say
dead drop because it's
you know for a human in human terms it's
still crazy maybe h5 comes in
oh bishop takes g4 and then queen takes
d3 no that's what he played
for me it shows queen h4 yeah queen h4
makes a lot of sense too by the way
because you're threatening knight h2
bishop e4 wow anyways apparently this is
still a draw
but our opponent finally collapsed by
developing the bishop
allowing us this interception tactic
rookie two boom
boom
so much fun stuff going on here ladies
and gentlemen
and so many mistakes obviously
um but what a game i mean i mean these
concepts i think are always so beautiful
with that knight
and the perpetual and the smothered
mates so the the
sacrifice was extremely unsound of
course but uh
i think it was instructive and i think
was totally worth it it was an amazing
wait
we didn't get a chance to display too
much of it and remain behind the scenes
but
it was a fun game nonetheless an
instructive game and i hope you guys
enjoyed
uh that search for beauty uh
it it you know it just shows you
[Music]
something i i always talk about with my
friends you know they say well
isn't it uh an obstacle uh
isn't it isn't it a big deal that that
now a computer is on your phone can be
any human can be magnus carlsen you know
doesn't that discourage you well
not really because when we have these
games i know that i'm wrong on all of
these counts i'm not seeing anything
here
but it doesn't diminish our search for
beauty
it doesn't diminish the actual beauty of
some of these concepts and
it merely enhances our ability to
appreciate that
uh yeah that's definitely something
that's a great point
trans girl treasures i was reading in
gelfand's book that because of some line
he saw in a previous move
obstructed his thoughts so that my coach
would always tell me
remember that you're playing in
tournaments to win games not to write
tactics books
because i would always fall in love with
some particular concept and i would try
to make it work
and i knew that it didn't work but i
kept trying to make it work and kept
thinking well if he does this maybe it
works
that's a phenomenal point when you're
playing a tournament
you want to make sure that you're being
realistic and in
english essay writing my teacher used to
say
kill your darlings that's a famous
expression sometimes the sentences
that you cling to the most are the ones
that are holding you back
and it's the same with ideas sometimes
it's that one idea you keep trying to
make work
it makes you blind to the other ideas so
you got to be very mindful of that but
in this particular context
obviously we're looking for beautiful
ideas and we're trying to play well but
that's a
that's a great point thanks for bringing
that up
okay i think that's a great spot to call
the speedrun today guys that was a
that was a super fun game i'm really
really pumped about games like that